okay so um I saw I wanted to point out a
dynamic that we have from Megan the
stallion so Megan the stallion is the
popular Entertainer rapper and social
media star she pressed um she famously
uh arguably me to Tory Lanes now Tory
Lanes is in jail um because she said
that he shot her the evidence was very
weak but somehow he he's still in jail
anyways so Megan the stallion is known
for sleeping around the industry many
rappers entertainers ball players have
said they have slept with Megan the
stallion and she was talking about it on
a live and how she is going to
be stingy with the cootie cat in the
future all
right it's like nobody be listening to
my music they be like Megan the stallion
I cannot believe she likes to have
six I cannot believe Megan the stallion
[__]
b y
be no but I am turning over you know a
new
leaf and I'm stinging with a Cy
cat I'm not a freak
anymore oh my
God I'm done I'm done with the shs so
toxic in the
stets
I'm tired of the
streets okay so this tends to happen to
women around late 20s early 30s where
they suddenly find God now I'm not
disputing that some women genuinely do
find God around this time but oftentimes
women use this as a mating strategy in
order to compete for men they no longer
have the looks that they used to when
they are younger so they have to
prioritize other things like a
relationship with God and the problem is
and and she didn't say God or church in
this obviously um but you know she said
stingy with the cotie the cotie cat um
and basically women reached this phase
around 27 to 32 roughly years old it
depends on the looks of the woman where
she realizes she cannot compete in the
sexual Marketplace like she used to um
so the comment section had a lot of
suitors for Megan I'm sure that said
they're really excited
to compete for this cotie cat that she
is stingy with uh you can't be stingy
with the community
cat Megan the mileage and it's great to
hear that Megan the stallion is focusing
on her well-being and making positive
changes in her life setting boundaries
and being more selective about who she
shares her personal time and energy with
is a healthy step towards self-care and
personal growth so around this age this
is when women tend to pick the safer guy
um and you can see this in with dating
appd based on like what we select for in
our early 20s it tends to be things like
nice car nice watch uh late 20s to early
30s it tends to be more long-term
retirement house um like early 20s women
tend to pick more for a lifestyle later
20s early 30s women tend to pick more
for long-term security um and the
problem is men do not and ladies I'm
just going to explain this men can't
stand this they cannot stand the idea of
paying more for a product that other men
got for free now I know you might not
view yourself as a product I I totally
get it but this is how men view it uh
the idea that other men have you know
done the commun the community cooe
cat I don't know um with virtually no
effort and now she would ask the next
guy to put in a lot of effort is rough
men men do not like this um and men will
always put up with it but this is why
myin and them have rules like if she
doesn't sleep with you on the first day
date go to the next chick because she
has done it for somebody and the problem
is even women that maybe this is their
you know standard doubt it but sorry
don't got that and even even women you
know even women that aren't like that um
unfortunately with the marketplace the
men all kind of assume there is
something in this modern world so a lot
of times modern Women Want It All We
want to make money on only fans and then
we want to just
sell our butthole for
$9.99 and then get a husband
after but a lot of times what isn't
spoken about is the cost that comes with
the average only fans model makes
roughly 500 a month she doesn't make
much I I think it's actually less than
that I have to look it up but so I saw
this crazy video of a woman talking
about I I just need to show the video a
woman talking about her experience on o
to me having my only fans account I had
had this subscriber almost since the
beginning he had spent around $2,000
Australian dollars bought every single
thing that I sent him we haded every day
on there and he had a very specific
username that was not a like
automatically generated one or anything
like that and an account with the same
username had viewed my Tik Tok profile
when I could see who was viewing it at
the time um and yes I had the exact same
username and it said from your contacts
and my heart just sank into my stomach
and I was like I don't have that many
phone numbers in my phone I know who
this person is and he has spent this
much money on my account seen everything
and I just sort of went into Super
detective mode and I said I need to find
out who this is I went through all of
the contacts in my phone I crossed out
anybody who had a established Tik Tok
account and crossed out the people that
said invite to Tik Tok and I was left
with six names it was a couple of guys
from school one girl from school
someone's mom and my stepdad and I had
just thought okay it could be those guys
but I feel like they would have told me
like they always messag me happy
birthday it's not going to be them it's
not going to be my girlfriend it's not
going to be this mother it has to be my
stepdad wow so I went out on a limb and
messaged the account on only fans and I
said I know who this is and he responded
saying who question mark babe you don't
know and I then hit back pretty quickly
and I said you need to tell her before
my sister and I do and with her being
your mom yeah being my mom and within 2
minutes I got a text message from my
stepdad saying Tay you're free to talk
so I want to talk about how the sin of
the mother is passed down to the
children I have interviewed so many only
fans models and so many times they come
from a home either with a weak father or
no dad at all now you have a woman who
is sexually irresponsible to the point
where she brought home a man that is
sexually going after her daughters now
when you're a kid your house and home is
supposed to be the place where you feel
free where you it is supposed to be a
safe haven and this woman has grown up
with a man that has been looking at her
like that from a young age that is
disgusting this this is some of the
consequences that come from out of order
bringing random men into the home women
this this is like the greatest sin of
all sins bringing home a random man to
raise your daughters I really do not
believe that women should even try to
remarry I I really don't I really think
you made your bed you should give the
kid to the dad because imagine being
that woman's ex-husband I mean it's very
clear that whoever was her dad was not
in her life because she wouldn't be on o
or he wasn't a strong enough influence
to keep her out of that direction and
her stepfather clearly was encourage in
it and this is actually disgusting but
it also shows that the stepdad is one of
the most likely people to abuse the kid
okay so the comment section comes in and
says a nightmare of One's Own creation
yeah this whole story is just messed up
um she won't be getting any sympathy
making of is immoral and immoral meets
immoral right exactly the audacity she
has to assert any sort of moral
superiority and the crowd is just as
hypocritical as she is yeah
no
actually I mean and that's the thing
they all comfort her when really it's
like you made your bed you got a lie in
it but what I want I want you guys to
notice the dynamic that tends to happen
when you meet of models there's two
things it's either a weak father or no
father at all and typically you can tell
it's a weak father because he doesn't
disown her and oftentimes the mother
starts encouraging her to go on o and
the dad supports it and what does that
tell us usually when there an outof
order household it's because the woman
believes she's above the man or leads
the household